afraid i don't got a choice mitch
looks like we don't have one say i
missed you the whole clan knows we set
out tomorrow
they know why what our aim is look
around v
war-tested veterans are a fistful at
most the rest mostly raid rinky-dink
convoys and salvage scrap
so for now they only know as much as
they need to know the plan is solid the
aim is to help
not now we're sending this clan to its
grave
[ __ ] you think i don't know that and yet
you seem to think you can change
something by chewing me out like you
usually do
v finally how's your health
been better so what have you guys
patched together
we still have details to iron out but we
know the who where and how
have a look for yourself a few
strategies we sussed out
but only one grants us a decent shot at
penetrating arasaka tower
we'll dig a tunnel
so you want to tunnel into our soccer
tower
i know how it sounds but would be plumb
fools not to take advantage i see
nightcorps building a new maglev line in
the area
granted it's guarded by militech but
they're nothing we can't handle once
we're in that tunnel
it's just half a mile to the substratum
levels of arasaka tower
they're using what a nightcorp circs
would only need a few minutes to dig
that distance not bad wouldn't you say
once we're in we'll have to improvise
guards security measures
the fastest way into mikoshi we'll take
things as they come and hope for the
best
v any thoughts
plan entire op it's about heading into
enemy territory
you'll make enemies of arasaka and
others
so it appears i'm exposing you all of
you
to danger want out want to cut your
losses
i'd understand no hard feelings you came
to us for help
we decided we provided our minds are
made up
no more discussion needed it's settled
we'd best get to work
i'll talk to our brothers and sisters
get a drone buzzing over that site
and i'll check with mitch i think i know
how to even the odds against militech
come find us later i'll leave you in
saul's hands now
just no making decisions without me
is there anything else you need
i need a decent neck connection someone
i know can help us get into mikoshi
who might that be
alt she's it's
an a.i from i'll pass a black one are
you fully present up there
why in hell would an ai help us break
into because they'll ask it to
nicely [ __ ] maybe
you know what fine we're up to our balls
and dung
anyway might as well go deeper
find dakota she'll get you geared up no
questions asked
thanks so thank me once we get out of
mikoshi alive and in one piece
[Music]
that america's long gone and forgot
you might as well have started with once
upon a time fellas
we heard we're gearing up for a minor
war more like a suicide mission finish
it up here
all right lo and behold
isn't this in theory we fitted an
afterburner and a multi-rpg
launcher up top we also scooped out
about
60 of its total mass beautiful isn't she
you'll take the wheel with pan am riding
shotgun
afterburner standard nitro or military
grade
standard couldn't move this baby an inch
it's a hardware's military
but how the hell did you cram all that
into a panzer oh
small beans compared to the tricks we
pulled with scorpion during the war
when we unleash this beast tomorrow
you'll see
fire power up top what is it
a rapid fire 70 millimeter multiple
rocket launcher coupled with an
onboard mmi you can sync to via personal
link where'd you get all this stuff
teddy salvaged it from a scrapyard the
launcher itself was fine
the problem was no ammunition as luck
would have it
dakota procured some don't ask me how
[Music]
[Music]
hey dakota it's been a long while
what is it you need need a strong rig
for a little jaunt on the net okay get
in
gonna be hitting a masked encrypted bbs
prefer nobody knew i was there your tech
up to it
up to it he asks heading for the wild
frontier dakota you have all you need to
pierce through to the other side
you need in fear brian eyes
eyes filled tub favorite [ __ ]
[Applause]
carol here to help dakota
evidently i'm here to help you today you
good to go
can't say how long this is gonna take
whatever happens stay cool all right
even if you look like you're about to
flatline
all right time to move follow the
vectors brother
[Music]
hello alt
you come alone
johnny's currently indisposed currently
he is buried deeper you treat him like
an unwanted passenger
a backseat dreamer of a world not his
own
seemed to me you didn't care a lick
about johnny that he ceased to exist for
you even
if he did not exist you and i would have
nothing to discuss
let me get this straight mean to say you
only agreed to help me because of johnny
and since he's not here this one time
you're thinking of backing out
i do not aim to back out i have my own
intentions for mikoshi
because for a second you were displeased
and i seemed a side note to all this
to observe the two of you interacting
informative
i need your help walt don't got a lot of
time left
you truly believe time to be your
greatest concern
you exist or you do not exist two states
of being separated by death
[Music]
matter of perspective think what you
will but seems to me i rose from the
dead
only question is what now you believe
you cheated death
it is death that has treated you you
are in between you will begin to
understand
but only in mikoshi
what should i expect there in mikoshi
a boundary to cross in all likelihood
the sole moment of your life when you
feel the true weight of your existence
a burden for which you cannot prepare
i'll make it through while mikoshi will
not
constructs imprisoned there gonna set
them free
they will be integrated with me
[Music]
wasting time talking let's just do this
there i sent a program to your netrunner
shard
once inside mikoshi use it
it opens a secure connection
should i look for a specific access
point i can already tell you ice all the
way to tokyo be back in every single one
some need but a barely cracked door to
enter
use the shard in negotiator leave the
security to me
until then
we got him back carol the shard relax
child you barely jacked him when the
temperature went skyward to almost 100.
the text started
acting as if infected no stranger
spookier what happened here
you melted half my tech that's what
happened neural activity spiked sharply
your frontal lobe was seconds away from
flowing out your ears babe
i could just as well have popped a
bullet in your head
are you sure you're all right
peachy good real good hey what about a
flick
it's sharp i've been out in a while i
wrote some soft i need to one of the
shorts
please we're surrounded by it even if
something punched through my controllers
would have
holy get it away from me
thanks dakota don't thank me
find saul he came around looking for you
on my way
excuse me i didn't mean to
so you want an award hop up here
are we going somewhere all right
it's a simple matter we all of us
standing here
oh you and it's a great death speak for
yourselves so
but in spite of that there's still an
outsider
the mercenary from night city what might
as well be another world
hey ask pan am she knows it's about time
we fixed that down right in justice it
is
it needs fixing it's gonna be an
aldecado
which means this family will go to hell
and back to you
ready kid do your worst
you're one of us now b you're an
aldocaldo dammit
thanks for everything don't worry we'll
get you into that makoshi
isn't that the way of it welcome to the
family
a warm welcome for our newest al docaldo
come on video welcome to the class don't
know what to say
it's about time you did it no like
i really don't never expected this
thank you don't worry
it's but a formality you've been a de
facto member of this family for a while
now
you saved my rompers and as bobby tells
it mitch is too
i won't even mention pan am go to hell
it's all right though i mean let's face
it v my life was in a million pieces
you broke it into a million more
sometimes it's only then that you can
piece it together again
all right fam listen up today we
celebrate but tomorrow is shaping up to
be a hell of a day
do whatever needs doing then get some
rest a raid is arranged to you
[Music]
could have given me a heads up about
this and ruined all the fun
are you kidding are you all right
yeah it's nothing
don't worry about it and how's the
jacket
not too tight
snug is a glove feels like i've been
wearing it a while
don't you
i'll be up there
of course anything else
mom i might have you have to look around
what's this so maybe i'll
take some sources essentially in his
dakotas
today the occasion would be
the end times worthy gesture
dramatic even actually pragmatic i'm
giving away my stuff to you so you
survive tomorrow's mad health
and come back
there's a nice spot up there quiet would
you rather be alone
maybe oh please i just need to get away
from everything but for a minute
to gather my thoughts before tomorrow
try not to bother you then
[Music]
so nice here
[Music]
any for your thoughts i have none
i mean i don't even know i'm so tense i
barely caught a wink last night
it's likely to be the same tonight
what's eating you
well let's see tomorrow i'll leave my
whole clan to near certain death
as if that's not enough saul is suddenly
concurring with everything i say
and i don't even know if that's good or
bad [ __ ]
people are doubting us i can feel it
but they still believe it all goes to
[ __ ] pan am will be there for them
because who else right
exactly who if not you that's what i
mean
it shouldn't be me it should be so
if only he hadn't gone and made all the
wrong decisions to be a little more like
me
i'm scared to the bone something will go
wrong that everyone will
nobody's dying tomorrow pan am you don't
know that
the fam they're tougher than you think
bullets don't distinguish between tough
and weak
v yeah are you not afraid to die
i try my damnedest not to think about it
so do i
but the harder i try the worse it gets
time to head back maybe
no let's sit here a while longer
this is doing me good more than i
thought
all right let's go before our asses
freeze over saul's back
let's go maybe he turned up something
new